[Music]
Hey it's me, Destin.
If you have ever flown
then you have observed
this condensation that
builds up on the window,
where the, uh... the water
transitions to ice.
But I'm gonna show you a trick to show you
some really neat ways to photograph that.
So this is all you do: you take
your lens and you pop it off...
Hard to do with just one hand.
Just pop your lens off,
and rotate it, like this.
So you can make a quick macro lens
that also acts as a microscope,
and you can see the transition
between water bubbles and ice.
And you can take some really neat photos.
Like this.
That's it. It's quick and easy to do,
and you don't need any special equipment.
You can buy an adaptor, and I'll put
that information in the "more info".
Here you go, you are now smarter every day.
Thank you Papa.
- No problem.
[Captain speaking in French]
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.